hi Brian my name is Mike braless I'm
with Forbes media and the most
interesting idea that I've heard today
not really an idea but I just came from
an exercise called the refugee run and
it's run by an organization called
global hand crossroads and it's an
extraordinary simulation of what life is
like in a refugee camp and I'm actually
you know businessman and I'm here
attending the world economic forum but
after that experience in few minutes ago
it's really all I can talk about for the
next couple of minutes you are put into
the situation of being a homeless
refugee pushed around and shuttled in
the dark and with with no no resources
into a refugee camp and you stay there
and experience in a very very real
simulation what that's like so the I
guess it's not the most interesting idea
but the realization that there are 43
million people at least refugees in the
world who are experiencing what I just
went through a simulation of at any
given point in time is is remarkable to
me so that's the idea I'm trying to
grapple with and I'm not sure if that's
what you were looking for but that's
what's on my mind thanks